(whooshing)
- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk about
the seven reasons why you haven't achieved
your ultimate goal.
- [Robot] Nine.
Eight.
(heavy-bass electronic music)
- So I get a lot of
entrepreneurs writing into me
asking me comments on YouTube,
sending me snaps and Instagram questions.
They're basically saying
I have these goals,
I know what I want to
do, I have this vision,
it's so clear in my head,
but I'm not following through,
I'm not doing the work.
I haven't been able to achieve my goal yet
and I thought I would have
already done it by now.
What's the problem?
So I'm going to share
with you the seven reasons
why you haven't achieved your goal
and hopefully, if some of
them resonate with you,
you can fix it so that you can
achieve your goals this year.
(rhythmic music)
Reason #1 is you're afraid of failure.
This is one of the biggest reasons
why people don't get started.
It's easy to think of an idea,
it's easy to put yourself there.
You're on that island 'cause
you've sold this company,
you've had so much success
and you just see the impact that you have
and you're winning awards
and whatever it is,
and it's fun to kind of live
in that fantasy land for awhile.
But then the other side comes
in when you're afraid like
what if it doesn't work?
What if I lose my money?
What if things go under,
what if I lose my house?
What if, what if, what if, what if.
What if my relationship falls apart?
All of these negativities that come in.
And so understanding that that is a story
that you're holding yourself back on,
because most people are afraid of failure
but they'll mask it with
some practical reason
why they can't do it.
That's the biggest reason.
That's the biggest thing that
holds people really back.
Really you're just afraid
to go out and do it,
you're afraid of failing,
but you've convinced yourself
that it's for a practical reason
that you're not going to get started.
You tell yourself that you
don't have the education,
you don't have the money, or
now is not the right time,
or you're just too busy right now
or blah blah blah blah blah.
Some kind of reason, right?
But really at the core of it, it's just,
you're afraid of failing.
And so recognizing that all the excuses
that you have in front of
you are just BS excuses,
that other people have already
had way more success than you
with way fewer resources
and education and talent
than you have within yourself,
you have nobody to blame but yourself
from recognizing that it's just fear
that's holding you back,
allows you to address the problem,
allows you to mitigate
the fear, to minimize it,
to go after your goal and do
something not necessarily
on a big scale yet,
but taking small steps.
So every step along the way
you're reducing more fear,
reducing more fear, reducing more fear.
Understand the real reason
that's causing you to not go
forward on your goal,
and break through those BS excuses
that you're telling yourself.
(rhythmic music)
#2 is you're afraid of being judged.
This one is a super scary one too.
It's not just a fear of failing,
it's the fear of failing
in front of other people.
What will people think
if you don't do well?
What will people think by
your idea if it's not perfect?
What will people think if
you make a YouTube video
and you post it, and it's
not perfect, it's not great,
it's not the best you can do.
What will your parents think
or your husband or wife think
or your kids think or your
high school classmates think
or your university friends think
if your thing doesn't work out?
And what it forces people to do
is then play small,
because you're so worried about
what other people will think,
that when you want to
start coming up here,
you smash yourself back down.
There's a Japanese phrase
I'm going to butcher
but there's a saying basically where
if your nail is sticking
out you get hit back down.
Right, so it's conformity.
If you want to live a life of conformity,
then you're always going to be
exactly like everybody else around you.
Nobody's going to ever
create anything unique,
'cause you're all trying to be vanilla
'cause you're afraid of being
judged for somebody else.
And so again, recognizing
that that's your fear
and developing the muscle
to break through it,
for me, whenever I try to do,
when I'm worried that I'm being judged,
when I'm worried about
somebody else's opinion of me,
then I force myself to go through with it.
Not in a way that's offending them.
It's not to shove it in their face and say
hey look what I did
but me, on my path.
So I've told this story
about when I was walking,
to trying to dance salsa,
and had music on, right?
And I'm bouncing and grooving
and I'm jiving on the street
and then I got to the busy intersection
and I started doing
much smaller movements.
Just subconsciously.
We do this subconsciously.
We fear judgment subconsciously.
And when I recognize that,
then I force myself to dance
big on the street again.
Even as I'm doing it right now,
there's people walking by me
to the side, watching like,
what's this guy doing,
dancing in the studio?
Doesn't matter right?
Feeling that discomfort and
working your way through it,
builds the muscle so you
can do it again and again,
each time in more powerful ways.
So any time you feel that
you're holding yourself back
from doing something that
you really want to do,
because you're worried about
being judged by somebody else,
then that's a signal in my mind at least
that you need to go out and do it.
You have to force yourself
to feel the discomfort
and break through it,
so that you're building the
muscle for the next time,
it doesn't happen.
And the next time, you're stronger.
And the next time you're
able to break through
and do something even bigger.
Fear of somebody else's judgment of you,
should not be the reason why
you don't chase your dream.
(rhythmic music)
#3 is the fear of success.
This is a crazy-sounding one.
Why would I fear success?
A lot of people do.
For the negative ones
it's easier to understand.
You're afraid of failure,
you're afraid of judgment,
that's easy to understand.
But why would I be afraid of success?
For a lot of people,
that means that they're going
to leave their situation,
they may leave their family,
they may leave their friends behind.
They're going to leave
their community behind.
As they move off to some other place.
And that's scary.
And a lot of people
will then self-sabotage.
They'll reach a certain level of success
and then they'll sabotage
themselves to fall back down
because they don't want to
leave the people behind them.
And again it's the idea of playing small.
Because all these people around you
are not chasing their dreams,
are not doing the thing
that they want to do,
are not recognizing their genius-level,
Micheal Jordan-level talent
at whatever they're doing.
They don't want to go off and do it,
and so it makes you feel like
you don't want to go off and
do it as well.
And as soon as you start rising up,
a lot of times people will
then sabotage themselves
to fall back down because
it's more comfortable
to be in their current environment.
That's why the environment
is so important.
We'll touch on that a little bit later.
So if you've ever reached the point
where you've had some success
and then you find yourself
getting in your own way,
ask yourself if you're afraid of success,
if you're afraid of more success,
if you're afraid of
leaving your group behind,
'cause that limited belief
is holding you back.
(rhythmic music)
The #4 reason why you haven't
achieved your ultimate goal yet
is you just don't care enough.
A lot of people set the wrong goals.
A lot of people, when you say
what is your ultimate goal,
they come up with something that
actually doesn't motivate them.
They want to buy a Ferrari,
that's their ultimate goal.
You don't actually care that
much about buying that Ferrari.
The thing that you say that
you care so much about,
you don't actually care
that much about it.
Happens to a lot of people.
It's one of the main reasons why
entrepreneurs fail, why 80 to
90% of companies shut down,
depending whatever stat you follow,
'cause they just don't care
enough about their business.
They got into it for the wrong reasons.
You have to love your craft.
If you look at all the
videos that we've done,
all the famous entrepreneurs
that we've profiled,
it's one of the most consistent messages.
You have to love what you do.
So if you're doing something
for the wrong reason
you're never going to
get to that finish line.
One good way to figure it out,
is if you knew you'd
never make money at this,
would you still do it?
I love helping entrepreneurs.
It's in me, it's in my fabric.
I love it.
I would do it even if
I wasn't making money.
In fact, most of the
time I'm not making money
when I'm helping entrepreneurs.
I just love it.
I fills me up, it fuels me.
And when I first started along this path,
I had three people show
up to my first free event
and I thought I'm never going
to make money doing this.
But I just loved it so
much I had to find a way.
You might have to do other things.
This I'd continue doing
because I love it so much.
You have to love your work that much.
You have to love the person
you're with that much.
You have to love your life that much.
You have to love that
goal you have that much
that you would do it,
even if it didn't make any sense,
even if it never made you any money,
that you would still do it.
If you have that level of
care, then you'll get there.
Most people don't because
they picked the wrong goals.
(rhythmic music)
Reason #5 is you are not consistent.
This happens to so many entrepreneurs.
We're not consistent.
You may have one day where you're on fire
and energetic and closing deals
and working hard and
grinding and hustling,
and then the next day you're
not working as hard anymore.
And it's this roller coaster
ride of up and working hard
and then nothing,
and then up and working
hard and then nothing.
And oftentimes that may be
because you read a book,
you listened to a podcast,
or you watched a video
and that got you inspired,
but you're not consistent.
Consistency is going to be the key.
If you look at the people who
are the greatest in the world
at what they do,
they practiced.
Whether you believe in a
10,000 hour rule or not,
they practiced.
They put their hours in.
They worked hard.
I've made almost 4,000
videos on this channel.
That's a lot of videos.
You better get half-decently good
after you've done something,
whatever it is, 4,000 times.
And so you have to be consistent.
You have to find a way to make sure
that every single day, even
if you have a job right now,
you have other responsibilities right now,
it's fine, I get it.
It's not that you have to go full time,
you have to burn the boats
and forget everything else
happening in your life,
but it also doesn't mean that
you do work only on Mondays
and the rest of the week,
you've got nothing else.
You're busy with the rest of your life.
You're not going to get anywhere.
If you practice at something once a week,
you're not going to get anywhere.
Has to be daily.
You have to find a time
to spend time daily
at least 30 to 60
minutes every single day,
on your business, on
achieving that ultimate goal
to allow the momentum to build up.
Most of you aren't hitting it
because you're not consistent enough.
(rhythmic music)
#6 is your environment sucks.
I touched on this a little bit earlier
but the environment you're in matters.
You are likely to be like your parents.
You're likely to be like your friends.
You're likely to be like
the people around you.
It's really hard to break through.
How do you break through?
You start changing those things.
And you may say well I don't know how
to hang out with different people,
I don't know how to get access to them,
if you're a face-to-face person
then go start to meet them,
go to events, go to
conferences, go to meet-ups,
go to the places where the
people who you want to be like,
people who you want to
associate with are hanging out.
'Cause it may not be in your backyard.
It may not be on the
streets where you grew up.
For me, it came from books initially
and now it comes from videos.
I feel like I'm hanging around Steve Jobs
and Oprah Winfrey and the people
that I profile on my channel.
I feel like every time
I watch their videos
a little piece of them,
their thinking, their mindset
their way of being seeps into me,
not to help me become like them
but to help me become
a better version of me.
To help me play a bigger game,
to help me have more confidence,
to help me believe more.
So those are the people
that I hang out with
on a consistent basis,
because to be honest a lot of my friends,
they're not pushing me.
This happens for a lot of entrepreneurs.
Your friends don't push you.
Your friends respect you,
your friends might be jealous of you,
your friends might be saying
what you're doing is really stupid,
or they may be saying
I wish I could do what you're doing.
But who's telling you
you're doing a good job
and you should be doing more.
You should be playing way out here
and you're playing this small game.
A lot of us don't have that
because we don't have a boss.
That's what a good boss
does, a good mentor does.
They see the untapped potential in you
and they help you get
to where you should be
as opposed to where
you're limiting yourself.
We don't have that a lot as entrepreneurs.
We are our own boss.
And yes, sometimes our
clients will push us
and we'll have to make deadlines
and those kinds of things,
but in general, you know
you could be working harder.
You know you haven't reached your ceiling,
and you're not pushing
yourself through the discomfort
to go and reach that potential,
because there's nobody out
there doing it for you.
And so creating the environment
that forces you to go out and do it,
whether it's finding mentors,
whether it's finding new friends,
whether it's watching videos,
whether it's listening to podcasts,
whether it's consuming
books, whatever it is,
look at the things that are around you,
your environment.
What's on the wall in front of you,
all of those things matter.
You want to create an environment
and a morning routine, especially rituals,
that get you set up to do
something amazing today.
We've all felt those moments of boldness
where you felt unstoppable,
where things would be amazing for you,
and then the rest of
the week kind of sucked.
So whatever you felt,
whatever was happening
that got you all jazzed up and excited,
whether you were watching an
interview or whatever it was,
do that first thing
every day in the morning.
And you'll need to find different sources
because if all you're doing
is listening to the same video
every day, you're going
to get bored of it.
It may last for a week and then
it's going to lose its effect.
But another video could help you
and then another video could help you
and another video could help you,
which is why I started
the entspresso series
as a morning daily
thing to give you a shot
of ideas and inspiration
and wisdom and energy
to go and do something
powerful and amazing
in your business and your life today.
Whether you watch the
entspresso series or not,
it doesn't matter to me,
but find something that
makes you feel bold, inspired
and energetic and do that
first thing in the morning,
every single day to set
yourself up for success.
(rhythmic music)
And the #7 reason why
you have not achieved your ultimate goal
is just a lack of self awareness.
As I've been going through this process
of helping people find their one word,
I found how little people
actually know about themselves.
How often people have sat in the industry
just because that was the
practical thing to do.
That's what their
parents wanted them to do
or that's what they started university
so they just kept along that path,
and people have very little self-awareness
for who they actually are,
and what do they value.
If you don't know what you stand for,
then you're just going to be subject
to what other people stand for.
Everybody has a plan for you.
Your parents, your friends,
your colleagues, your customers,
your suppliers, your investors.
Everybody has a plan for you
or what you should be doing
with your life that serves them.
If you don't have a
great plan for yourself,
you're just going to be
following everyone else's plan.
You're never going to
get anywhere amazing.
And so whether you believe
in finding the one word
and applying that to your
life and your business,
or you go some other path,
the idea of self-awareness
is really important.
Why I find it so helpful is because
I've realized that everything in my life
has led up to where I am right now.
And believe has always
played a part in it.
Believe is my one word.
It's always played a part of it.
My favorite songs are about believe,
my favorite movie is Seabiscuit,
which is about believe,
my parents taught me believe.
Everything that's been good in my life,
came through the lens of believe.
But it happened at random.
These random moments of
greatness happened to me.
When you understand what your one word is,
when you have this self-awareness,
then now you can take
that and start planning
to let these good things
happen to you on purpose
going forward,
that you recognize them,
that you start hanging
around the right people,
that you start making the
powerful clear decisions,
that you start getting results,
that you start achieving your goals.
Otherwise you're going to
continue to live a random path
and you're going to continue to live up to
other people's expectations
of what they want for you
instead of the life that
you want for yourself.
And so whether you're going with one word
or you have another tool to help you,
having a self awareness
to understand who you are,
what you stand for, why you're here,
what the powerful thing
is that you want to do,
makes a huge difference for
your clarity, for your focus,
and for your ability to follow
through and actually achieve
in that ultimate goal for yourself.
So those are my suggestions
on the seven reasons why
you have not yet achieved
your ultimate goal.
I'd love to know what do you guys think,
what was your favorite rule and why,
did I miss an eight, nine, 10
that you want to add to the list?
Let me know down in the comments.
Super curious to figure out
what you guys have to say.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Jelena Ostrovska from
www.jelenaostrovska.com.
Thank you so much, Jelena,
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)